there's a very interesting new poll from
the university of
southern california which is making
headlines because joe biden is winning
by 11.
i don't want to talk about that i've
already told you you know joe up 11 with
a margin of error of three and a half
means maybe joe is only
up four and if trump picks up a point
between now and november
you could have the exact same outcome as
in 2016. so i don't care about biden up
by 11.
what i care about in this poll is that
it looks at
non-voters from 2016 okay
in the united states embarrassingly
tragically disgustingly only about 55
percent of eligible voters
vote 45 percent of those who could vote
did not vote in 2016. the turnout was
55 the preliminary data
from the university of southern
california poll finds that
among those who didn't vote in 2016
but planned to vote this year 52
plan to vote for joe biden while only 32
plan to vote for donald trump and
another 16
say that they would vote third party now
it's also notable that
among those who voted third party in
2016
they are also leaning towards biden 41
of those who were third party in 2016
are going biden
while only 30 of 2016's third-party
voters are going for donald trump
that's huge and uh of the people
when you combine that 71 percent
of third-party voters from last election
are not voting third party this time
around which i think does go to
the understood significance of this
election
but i want to focus on the non-voters
okay
2016 non-voters who are going to vote
are leaning towards biden
the obvious question is how many people
is that
right if there's a hundred thousand
non-voters
from last time who are going to vote
that's very different
than if there are 10 million non-voters
from 2016
who plan to vote uh if indeed 52
of them are going to be voting for joe
biden and just as importantly
how many people are there who did vote
in 2016 and don't plan to
this time around no data on them another
important question but this is another
signal
that our instinct from a year and a half
ago continues to be proven true
we are way better off trying to just
mobilize people to vote
then we are trying to argue with
trumpists to get them to change their
minds
it's very clear that a majority of those
who didn't vote last time
if we can get them to participate that
helps joe biden
just finding non-voters from 2016 and
getting them to vote
helps joe biden if you can target it to
people who are already on the left but
didn't vote
that's the win spending time arguing
with trumpists
whose brains have turned to mayonnaise
uh is not a good electoral strategy and
then we get to the problem of voter
apathy in the united states
there is no question you know when when
45 percent of the
elect eligible voting public doesn't
vote
there's no question that part of the
problem is
we are not ingraining civic engagement
and the importance of voting
from a young age where if people are
growing up in households where
of course you vote is the default
if kids are not hearing in school as
early as whenever
we vote that is what you do uh if he
if that was the situation our turnout
would be far higher than 55 percent
that's one part of the problem
our voting system is also part of the
problem and we can't ignore that the
system we have dissuades voting
and if you look at other countries
without mandatory voting
with significantly higher turnout you
see that sometimes they have different
election systems new zealand has a mixed
member proportional system
their turnout last election was almost
80 percent germany has a mixed member
proportional system
their turnout was 76 percent we have a
first pass the post system
that perpetuates the two-party duopoly
and
dissuades voting at all now many of you
have called me during live calls and you
say
david what the hell is going on with
third parties why can't third parties
get going in the united states
part of it is the spoiler effect of the
first past the post
post system and part of it also is
campaign finance so there are many
problems here
i don't believe that the intent of the
founding fathers
was to create a system that dissuades
participation
but it's what it's become in the modern
voting era
from the standpoint of this election
let's target those who didn't vote last
time it's a good idea the data backs it
up
we can't bank on non-voters showing up
some of the least reliable voters
are people who didn't vote last time
unfortunately but
the numbers are on our side arguing with
trumpists is a waste of time
and the numbers show non-voters from
2016
much more likely to support joe biden
than donald trump i think it's an
interesting area to focus
on particularly in battleground states
from here on out
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video